i want to start with congratulations i
really enjoyed the movie and your
performance thank you but i am going to
start with the most important question
up front uh celtics or golden state
celtics
i like this answer yeah celtics i mean i
i love golden state i i think i think
they're going to win but the celsius
just got so much
like they got jaylen brown they got
jason tatum they got al horf if al
horford plays how he's been playing i
don't think that warrior's got a chance
how is it actually as a nba player do
you what is it like watching games that
you're not in do you sort of you must
see the game in a completely different
way for me um it's my second year in so
i'm so eager to get back out there now
that i'm watching like the second run of
playoffs western conference finals the
finals like now i'm like i need to get
there like this where i need to because
you only can watch one game of
basketball right now and that's the nba
finals so that's where i want to be this
is your first time making a movie
working with adam sandler what actually
surprised you about making a movie like
this that maybe you weren't expecting
going in i didn't know that it was the
same amount of hard work in basketball
that it is in filmmaking that's that's
one thing i didn't know which of your
friends and family freaked out the most
over you working with adam sandler ah
man i got a really young family so
i think i was the most freaked out out
of all of them for real yeah um i
believe and i could be wrong that uh
juancho
is the one who suggested you for the
role yeah for sure what do you get
someone for suggesting for getting you a
role in a movie like this what's the
gift the gift is a thank you i think um
yeah cause he's my brother so um and if
it was vice versa if the roads were
flipped reversed i would have did the
same like we need a hispanic dude that
can barely speak a little english you
know i'm saying that's my brother let me
stop that speak a little english but
speak 100 uh spanish i would have called
on juancho so i mean it was all love i
can only imagine what i i couldn't
believe how many nba people were in this
movie and what i was imagining is this
cameras are off and there are pickup
games going on yeah how tough were those
pickup games on set they weren't really
tough it was fun for real i mean because
you get to play with all the nba guys um
and bob and boba made it like super fun
for sure yeah he made it just super fun
do you mean the 22 year old yeah 22.
who's signing these 12 or 10 however he
is
that team made me laugh yeah you can
hear me laughing no for sure yeah
how many people on set um were like
because everyone works a different way
every actor likes to sometimes people
like to be quiet right before i take and
other people like music what was it like
on set like having the way you want it
to work with everyone else's process i
mean i'm super chill like no matter
where i'm at so before every scene i'll
just be on my phone like chilling and
then they'll be like are we ready then i
go out and we shoot the video you've
been in the nba for two years two years
yeah and i'm curious obviously like
growing up you see the nba college you
see the nba but then you step on the
court what what was like the biggest
like surprise about joining the nba that
like maybe you didn't see
from a distance how how spreaded the
floor is um
it's a it's it's a lot easier path to
get to the rim because
the floor is so much bigger than it is
in high school and college that uh that
i didn't know that i love that's
something i actually didn't know that
yeah and how that's so interesting
actually yeah um uh art and are you a
sneakerhead no not at all really
not even so did you have any sort of
criteria for what you wanted to wear in
the movie no i mean i had i'm sponsored
by adidas so i mean i had to wear adidas
here do you have a specific pair that in
an emergency you are grabbing when
you're like
to go to the gym no like emergency at
your house
gotta grab one pair what's the pair you
grab probably the human race yeah the
pharrell shoes yeah i believe you have a
dog named aunt junior right yeah exactly
i love animals and i'm curious how did
you how did you meet your quote unquote
best friend one of my best friends since
i was a young age um
his dad
who who i call like my uncle uh was
breathing he breathes dogs and i went up
his house and i saw his dog judo he got
a dog named judo and i'm like man this
dog behaves so good when you're around
bro like he was like man i'm bringing
him i'm gonna have a dog so i'm like i
want one and
he happened to be the only one that come
out that color that's like bluish and
i mean he just he great he's the best
dog in the world man are you one of
these people do you um i want to use the
term baby the dog i do everything i
sleep with my dog
i let my dog in the shower with me
if i'm using the bathroom i do
everything that i do my dog if i'm
working out my dog is coming
yeah my dog comes everywhere do you get
to take your dog with you when you're
traveling yeah
on the like the plane and everything
yeah that's amazing yeah um
that's
i i um i really wish i could have a dog
but no i love dogs yeah i love dogs but
my lifestyle doesn't allow it
i think you get treated a little you
know like you
you treat it maybe better on planes than
i would get treated with an animal maybe
you know but the only time i'm able to
bring my dogs is like when i fly private
so oh yeah so i can
i completely get it yeah what else are
you looking forward to did you get this
my last question i think or yeah sorry
did you catch the acting bug uh while
making this movie what's the acting bug
i don't know meaning like oh it's like
uh you had such a good time making the
movie that you want to make another
movie oh no i didn't catch that night
no i didn't catch that at all
i got i got the basketball bug right
on that note i'm just going to say it is
a pleasure meeting you
nothing but the best thank you so much
you